[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
kevin bossuet un professeur d'histoire
dans un collège de seine-saint-denis
bonsoir kevin bossuyt merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés julie garnier porte
parole de la france insoumise bonsoir
julie garnier merci également à vous
d'avoir participé à ce face à face
alors tout d'abord la première réaction
vient d'entendre ses parents un peu
déboussolé comment vous vous qualifiez 1
le professeur que vous êtes cette
rentrée kevin bossuet chaotique où
finalement plutôt bien organisé
non c'est une rentrée qui est plutôt
bien organisé on est dans un contexte un
peu particulier en effet où on voit
respecter certains gestes barrières qui
ne sont pas faciles à respecter
je pense par exemple au port du masque
il est vrai que pour des élèves de 6e
par exemple en collège il est très
difficile de conserver un masque que
toute la journée sur la figure mais
c'est également le cas évidemment des
enseignants qui doivent enseigner
enchaîné sept ou huit heures de cours
avec un mass notamment sur la bouche or
c'est pas facile
les trouve que quand même le ministère a
très bien géré cette crise puisque n'ya
le matériel nécessaire notamment au sein
de l'institution scolaire il ya du gel
hydroalcoolique les gestes barrières
sont respectés au maximum et je trouve
que c'est quand même très très bien fait
et voilà bravo à jean michel blanquer
pour cette rentrée qui est quand même
impeccable julie garnier je sens que
vous allez vous et on fait en tout cas
je vous vois faire des gros yeux vous ne
partagez pas la vie de kevin bossuet sur
cette rentrée plutôt bien organisé selon
lui il est professeur hawking est sur le
terrain moi aussi je suis sur le terrain
je suis parent d'élève et aujourd'hui
vous voyez j'étais dans une occupation
d'école primaire
parce que ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il
n'ya pas qu'eux en seine-saint-denis qui
ferme des classes mais c'est dans toute
l'académie de créteil s'est également
seine-et-marne c'est dans le
val-de-marne et on arrive à peu près à
une centaine de classes fermées ça c'est
la réalité et est actuellement la
réalité c'est que en maternelle on a des
classes qui vont se retrouver à 31
je dis bien 31 en maternelle et ça c'est
ce qu'on a constaté aujourd'hui avec des
parents d'élèves qui est occupé l'école
donc non visiblement non on n'a pas du
tout la même réalité c'est que quand on
va sur le terrain on se rend bien compte
que malheureusement la rentrée ne se
passe absolument pas bien mais c'est
normal puisque nous avons un jean-michel
bancaire qui n'a
absolument pas mis de moyens
supplémentaires alors que on sort d'une
période de post confinement c'est à dire
que les élèves devaient avoir plus de
soutiens devait avoir plus
d'accompagnement qu'on est dans un
protocole sanitaire qui a 31 dans une
classe de maternelle avec un seul
robinet vous doutez bien que ça ne sera
jamais respecté et que des classes tout
simplement à 30
c'est tout simplement insupportable et
inacceptable
donc ça vous voyez moi j'aime beaucoup
ce qu'ils disent que jean michel
blanquer a fait des bonnes choses et
préparer à tout mais quand on va sur le
terrain c'est complètement différent
et aujourd'hui on voit que
malheureusement les primaires les
élémentaires les maternelles sont
vraiment les abandonner et les sacrifier
même je dirais de cette rentrée c'est
vrai que ça fait beaucoup toute cette
classe fermée kevin bossuet qu'est ce
que vous répondez non mais je crois que
j'ai en face de moi il interlocutrice
qui est complètement dans l'idéologie
qu'on va véritablement un salon de
supputations aujourd'hui notion moi je
suis enseignant madame donc je vois ce
qui se passe concrètement sur le terrain
et je peux vous dire une chose c'est que
l'accompagnement personnalisé et mise en
place puisque pendant tout l'été jean
michel blanquer a mis en place les
vacances apprenantes qui ont permis
notamment à plein d'élèves d'origine
populaire de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
rattrapage scolaire et là le dispositif
devoirs faits et de les boire gratuits
proposés notamment à tous les enfants
notamment d'origine modeste va être
renforcé la vérité c'est que jean michel
blanc terre est un ministre qui lutte
contre les inégalités sociales
il fait plus contre les inégalités
sociales que la gauche a pu le faire
notamment en dix ou quinze ans au
pouvoir voilà moi je trouve que c'est
une très bonne rentrée les dispositifs
sont mis en place on ne rencontre pas de
gros problèmes sur le terrain
alors après évidemment je veux dire des
problèmes structurels au sein des
mutations nationales manque de
professeurs à certains pourquoi etc
mais ce n'est pas une idée notamment à
cette rentrée spéciale donc voilà donc
moi je suis un professeur de terrain et
je peux vous dire que ça fonctionne et
heureusement parce que mes élèves parce
que les élèves de la république ont
beaucoup souffert de ce confinement et
j'aimerais dire bravo notamment à tous
ces enseignants qui ont fait tout ce
qu'il fallait pendant cette phase de
confinement pour faire en sorte que
l'enseignement à distance culte se
poursuivre
alors justement on en vient à ce chiffre
un objet de notre débat près de 3900
élèves manquant à l'appel en l'éducation
nationale relative à ce chiffre il dit
que c'est une estimation non parce que
ça fait voilà beaucoup de monde 1,5 fois
plus que d'habitude c'est clémentine
autain votre parti à la france d'un
soumises qui soulève le problème vous
vous l'expliquez comment julie garnier
c'est 4000 près de 4000 élèves qui
manquait à l'appel en seine saint denis
notamment peur du virus déménagement des
décrochages après le confinement comment
quelle est votre analyse sur cette
question
l'analyse elle serait déjà que
l'éducation nationale plutôt que de
s'amuser à fermer des écoles et à fermer
des classes elle ferait mieux justement
de s'inquiéter de ce phénomène là or on
voit que l'éducation nationale est
restée bloquée dans le monde d'avant et
que leur première logique face à ça
c'est pas de chercher le problème c'est
juste de fermer des classes donc au des
gens ont peu un petit peu quand même
s'étonner de leur pratique
mais bien évidemment quand on est
manuelle macron qui dit dans une
interview que les enseignants ne font
pas partie du redressement économique
qui ne met aucun moyen supplémentaire
dans les écoles et moi on se doute que
finalement c'est pas un problème pour
eux et que ben moyennement dernier comme
ça fait moins de profs et ça fait moins
de frais ils sont restés dans une
logique comptable et c'est totalement
préoccupant maintenant j'aimerais juste
rajouter ceci c'est que avec des
personnes qui gardent cette logique
comptable
on est en train de vraiment sacrifié nos
enfants et je déplore vraiment que
l'interlocuteur face à moi renie
totalement la réalité du terrain et que
quand on lui dit qu'il ya 57 cas ce qui
ferme en seine et marne qu'il ya vingt
et une classes qui ferment en seine
saint denis et qu'il ya également des
casques et ferme en ville demain c'est
dire toute l'académie de créteil
il ne s'est donc pas je suis vraiment
perplexe de ces gens qui sont là juste
pour faire de la communication politique
et qui nous parle changer des gardiens
donnez moi mais après on fera régie à
kevin boss fait mais ce que c'est
forcément la faute
voilà de l'éducation nationale parce
qu'on rappelle quand même
pardonnez moi mais que l'école est
obligatoire il ya d'ailleurs des des
amendes assez lourde pour ce qu'ils
n'envoient pas leurs enfants à l'école
estienne forme aussi peut-être de
laxisme du côté peut-être des familles
je me fais l'avocat du diable mais il
faut se poser là
question ce département a énormément et
fiction est effectivement de défections
à la rentrée scolaire c'est forcément la
fois de l'éducation nationale le premier
laxisme il est vraiment du côté
l'éducation nationale écoutez il faut
commencer par y avoir qu'on fait on va
comparer avec ce que ce qu'ont fait les
autres par exemple les autres pays
européens
faut savoir que l'espagne a pris comme
mesure à la rentrée de ne faire aucune
classe au dessus de 20 élèves pour
justement garantir un véritable
protocole sanitaire est un véritable
soutien
nous n'avons fait aucun nous n'avons pas
fait ce choix jean michel blanquer a dit
non nous mettrons aucun moyen
supplémentaire quand vous avez vous avez
d'autres choix qui sont possibles vous
aviez été moyens qui étaient disponibles
or aujourd'hui on voit que ça va être
une hécatombe quand on a 28 écoles qui
sont fermés quand on a plus de 264 qui
sont fermés à cause justement du coc
vide eh bien on peut que regretter
véritablement que jean-michel bancaire
n'ai pris aucune mesure aucun moyen
supplémentaire pour défendre nos enfants
et pour rassurer les familles ça c'est
un fait
et malheureusement que les gens aient
pris peur où que ce soit tout autre
raison il faut d'abord voir la première
défaillance est le premier des laxisme
il est du côté de l'éducation nationale
et du gouvernement kevin boss fait vous
pensez que l'éducation nationale aurait
dû faire plus de pédagogie
peut-être rassurer ses parents inquiets
parce que c'est intéressant julie
garnier vous parliez d'espagne on va en
parler après c'est vrai que beaucoup de
parents ont aussi refusé de mettre leur
enfant en prévenant peut-être mais en
tout cas ils ont refusé
il ya ce laxisme du côté de l'éducation
nationale quand même kevin bossuet on
aurait dû faire plus de pédagogie mais
mais on en chie déjà je veux dire les
parents les reçoit on leur explique
notamment le protocole sanitaire on leur
explique comment leurs enfants elles
vont être accueillis puis on leur
explique ont pas respecté les gestes
barrières on va donner de l'enseignement
tout en essayant de préserver la santé
de tous moi ça me fait rire de voir une
représentante de la france insoumise me
dire que je fais de la communication
politique et je ne suis pas sur le
terrain puisque je suis enseignant je
suis professeur d'histoire géographie et
encore il ya quelques heures j'étais
dans ma salle de classe en train
notamment d'enseigner l'histoire
géographie donc ça fait plutôt rire et
moi ce qui me fait rire aussi ses
devoirs notamment cette dame donc avec
son éloquence naturel nous raconter que
si l'éducation nationale va mal c'est
parce qu'il ya un manque de moyens mais
en france on met beaucoup quand même
dans l'éducation nationale s'il part
budget qui est quand même grandi l'eau
et la vérité c'est que c'est l'idéologie
de madame garnier qui responsable du
délitement de l'éducation nationale
c'est toute l'idéologie soixante huitard
que cette militante de la france un sou
ni sport qui a fait en sorte que
l'autorité du maître et sans arrêt
remise en cause et même que l'autorité
de l'école est remise en cause
et quand je vois notamment les militants
de la france insoumise ce plat notamment
qu'il ya beaucoup de parents en seine
saint denis qui ont décroché avec
l'école alors que ces gens là ne cesse
d'être dans la mouvance islamo gauchiste
de surf et notamment pour toute cette
mouvance indigéniste est justement
décrochent les enfants de la république
de nos sols de naudi ya elle se fiche
quand même pas mal du monde donc au
moins qu'elle ne me reproche pas de ne
pas être sur le terrain alors que j'y
suis tous les jours a gelé garnier votre
a répondu oui
moi ce que je regrette c'est que ce
monsieur petit beaucoup de mots mais ne
donne pas beaucoup de chiffres il dit
que la france met beaucoup de moyens
mais je rappellerai juste que la france
est en dessous de la moyenne de l'oscd
eux concernant les dépenses publiques
par élève
ça c'est un fait on voyait bien que non
la france ne met pas du tout les moyens
qu'elle devrait mettre ensuite les
enseignants sont aussi en dessous de la
moyenne de l'oscd eux pour leur salaire
ils sont exactement entre la pologne et
la hongrie
tous que la moyenne de l'oscd le juste
pour encore donner un autre chiffre à
monsieur pour qu'ils se rendent bien
compte quand même de la précarité de
l'éducation nationale c'est que la
moyenne de l'oscd en primaire ses 21
élèves nous en france on est en moyenne
de 25
et encore on sent monter jusqu'à 30 31
comme je les dis quand j'ai cité cet
exemple de classe en seine et marne qui
se retrouvent à 31 élèves en moyenne
section exactement donc voilà le
problème des ce monsieur sait qu il se
dit beaucoup de phrases qui n'ont aucun
sens avec des mots dont il connaît pas
très bien les définitions également mais
les chiffres il les connaît pas et les
chiffres nous justement licite et ils
vont dans le sens où non l'éducation
nationale n'a pas les moyens qu'à mérite
en tout cas emmanuel macron s'est
adressé à la jeunesse 1 cet après midi
sur les réseaux sociaux il a fait passer
un message le président écoute et il n'y
aura pas de génération sacrifiée
c'était rapide
kevin bossuet justement la génération
sacrifiée
ce confinement c'était en tout cas l'un
des soucis affichée par le ministre de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer
est-ce que ce
ce confinement selon vous entraîner le
sacrifice d'une génération entière et
notamment sur le plan économique un ce
serait justement l'illustration avec ses
4000 élèves qui qui manquait à la
rentrée ou peut-être c'est un peu
prématuré de dire ça oui bien sûr
évidemment c'est les élèves les plus en
difficulté qui ont souffert notamment de
ce confinement puisque l'enseignement à
distance qui étaient mises en place
notamment au cours du confinement a
porté ses fruits pour les élèves
notamment qui étaient équipés où les
élèves qui avaient des parents derrière
eux pour les aider mais c'est vrai qu'à
liste cet enseignement est laissé sur le
côté notamment des élèves qui n'avaient
pas forcément la connexion internet
adéquat l'outil informatique adéquat qui
avaient des parents qui n'étaient pas là
pour les aider non et heureusement que
les professeurs de terrain était là qui
est professeur de terrain qui sont loin
de l'idéologie de madame garnier parce
que pendant que nous on était super
terrain les syndicats qui se
revendiquent de l'idéologie de madame
garnier faisait tout pour essayer de
trouver des justificatifs pour rester en
télétravail parce que apparemment ils
avaient peur peur du coup vide alors que
leur but était évidemment d'en faire le
moins possible
et moi j'aimerais quand même aussi citer
des études parce que moi je suis quand
même sur le terrain j'ai pas besoin des
chiffres pour matuidi pour maquiller
notamment montrent un conte inculture en
termes d'éducation nationale je prends
juste le classement pisa qui est quand
même le classement de référence qui
pointent notamment que l'un des
problèmes dans l'éducation nationale en
france et notamment le taux
d'indiscipliné dans les classes c'est à
dire c'est parce que à certains endroits
sur certains territoires de la
république
en fait on n'arrive plus à faire cours
normalement parce qu'il ya un tel degré
d'un discipline que finalement
l'instruction devient impossible et ça
c'est encore la conséquence que de
l'idéologie que porte madame garnier
donc elle a beau faire de faire pour
l'insulter à l'habitude vous êtes
invectives et je vous propose le voilà
la politesse et de vous laisser le mot
de la fin mais s'il vous plaît très
rapidement ce qu'on devrait déjà avoir
terminé donc peut-être une petite phrase
s'il vous plaît en réponse juste en
réponse en même temps quand on a que
l'insultent il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'arguments derrière juste quand même
rappeler les chiffres c'est que
malheureusement quand on a des classes
surchargées
quand on n'a pas les moyens et que avec
les enseignants qui ont fait ce qu'ils
pouvaient justement pour eux pour
poursuivre et d'ailleurs je rappellerai
juste qu'il ya quand même des
enseignants qui sont mort du co vite
donc il y ait au moins un peu de respect
pour ces morts là s'il vous plaît
je crois que oui malheureusement on est
dans une génération sacrifiée mais comme
tous les services publics avec monsieur
macron c'est toujours avec l'hôpital
avec l'école avec la justice etc et
services publics qui sont servis en
dernier
et malheureusement c'est la république
et les jeunes qui en souffrent les
premiers merci en tout cas on aura
compris que la seule solution de la
france insoumis c'est l'augmentation des
impôts c'est dire le mépris que cette
femme a notamment pour les impôts si
vous voulez avec plaisir en tout cas
vous avez de jouer tous les deux le jeu
du débat merci à vous deux kevin bossuet
julie garnier d'avoir été avec nous et
d'accepter donc face à face en direct
sur rt france